how would you like a homeless person as
your next roommate well it's no secret
that homelessness in liberal california
has gotten way out of control and now
things are getting so bad people are
being asked to open up their own homes
charities in the san francisco bay area
where an estimated 30 000 homeless
reside are asking landlords to allow the
vagrants to rent apartments at super low
rates and want families private families
to open up spare rooms as a charitable
act or in exchange for a small stipend
so you ready to do that jesse ready
right next to jesse junior's crib right
like a little comfortable area
with a spare door right there hide the
baseball bat maybe overnights that could
work you know sometimes you don't feel
like waking up at 2 a.m the government
has quit
yeah they've just said you know what we
can't do this anymore you take them
exactly i've never seen this happen
before well they did it with the border
um so now they're doing it with homeless
people and now they're also i think are
they buying crack pipes was that a real
story yes they're sending crack smoking
kits
right and there's a crack pipe in the
kit right right so it's like here's your
crack pipe take the homeless the border
is open we're just gonna fiddle around
with racism for the next three years
this is what we're dealing with geraldo
i mean no one would ever do no woman
would ever do it um no family would ever
do it it would probably be some like
mangy single dude just out of college
really hungry for some cash but that's a
roll of the dice but there are some
angie dudes right out of college looking
for a couple of bucks all in san
francisco
there and elsewhere yeah but i don't
know i don't think it's worth the risk
carol don't you know it better than
anybody
yeah member ed koch when he was mayor
sure
we had the liberal uh you know ethos
that be compassionate
ed koch stunned new york when he said
the mayor of new york said
pass them by give them nothing because
when you give them something they use it
to buy drugs or alcohol and it really
started a hardening
of new yorkers you know
establishment new yorkers toward the
homeless and i think it it has it made
the problem less severe well
you know i looked it up today because i
couldn't i couldn't figure out who's
responsible for this first of all as a
matter of fact california has the most
homeless people in the country best
climate too yeah okay and the best
climate maybe that's why they go there
maybe they don't okay i'm not gonna go
there there is an agency in the federal
government and it's called the united
states interagency council on
homelessness it is the only agency at a
federal level whose sole responsibility
it is to end homelessness and it works
with 19 other federal agencies they have
money they say the number one cause of
homelessness is the lack of affordable
housing we've got section 8 we've got
all that stuff that's what i read i'm
looking it up yeah
you're saying okay let's say it's wrong
i don't know what the reason is but what
i do is
okay mental illness that's fine
here's my point would i let him in my
house not a chance
not a chance because most of the people
that we're seeing right now who are on
the street who are taking bats to people
how many times have you heard they're
homeless they're homeless they've got a
mental health
illness they've got a mental health
problem we have to fix the mental health
uh problem maybe if you're fielding a
baseball team but you know not to sleep
over
seriously did you hear the thing in the
times i read that paper now dana got it
they had a report the guy that runs the
biggest homeless shelter in new york
city just got arrested for taking three
hundred thousand dollars in kickbacks
and his name is rivera rivera
you're related
no no relation please mayor adams did
say something very interesting today
dana he said uh
the
problem much of the problem lies in as i
mentioned with the judge
lack of facilities for the mentally ill
he wants to immediately create many more
beds for the acute you know the problem
is they get off their meds
he wants to create
you know not institutions but facilities
for the amendment the previous mayor
gave his wife a billion dollars to spend
on this very issue and then they had to
come out with a report a year and a half
ago that said whoops we have no idea how
that money was spent so if you talk
about compassion none of this is
compassion like letting people sit there
in their own filth is not compassionate
in any way and i do think that you know
the government giving up and saying
could you guys just take these people in
because that would be really helpful
what's the next step
you know i i do think that the question
about how many people we are allowing
into this country illegally this is that
question like will you take more people
in no at some point there has to be some
sort of tough love and i know greg has a
lot to say i'm going to leave it there
ugh are you into tough love today well
in many many ways geraldo i am
uh
this would make sense right if you were
talking about a child who lost their
family in a fire somebody who is
temporary without a roof but those
people exist
you can count them on your hands
metaphorically a giant hand that's not
the issue we've all seen the homeless
situation we've seen it up close we
don't need to pretend there are two
million children down on their luck
these are not children right these are
men
many are criminal many are mentally ill
many are drug addicts that's a fact that
you don't hear in these commissions on
on on homelessness right they painted as
just this the little teary-eyed people
that are down on their luck no they're
not these are not characteristics for a
sound roommate unless gavin newsom takes
four of them into one of his mansions i
do not believe this will ever happen you
brought up the idea of it's all about
affordable housing if you google stuff
on homelessness that's the number one
hit it's about affordable housing that
is a lie it has no effect on the
transient population if you do not
contribute to society through work the
only affordable housing has to be free
it doesn't matter if it's 300 bucks a
month or 200 but they're not going to
pay the money for most homeless goes to
drugs and alcohol i know that's
politically incorrect to say that it's
an unspeakable truth geraldo brought up
the idea that california has the most
because of the climate that's what you
call a choice right it's preferable so
it's many people prefer to be homeless
no rent no food to buy no bills find a
shelter free meals get drugs sustainable
lifestyle and you know why it's
sustainable or do you know the proof
that it's sustainable it's not shrinking
it's growing it's growing because it's
possible the idea that it's not enough
affordable housing that is true for
people who are working who who are who
have are low-income people yes but
they're not the homeless people do not
be tricked into this because that is why
we're not you think all the homeless
they just don't want anywhere to live i
think so why the who are they taking in
we've read about these this article that
this woman said i took a homeless person
look at the numbers there's there's you
could again you could count them that
it's so few that they can get they can't
match them the other thing that ed koch
did during his administration was to
give bus tickets to anywhere they wanted
to go
from anywhere you want to go
but then they had to go the cop would
take them to the port authority they get
on the bus for uh wherever then
wherever started saying we don't want
you either hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else